Luffy calls out the world government and
declares himself to be the next pirate
king directly to the gorosei Admiral
kizaru and the Marines begin an all-out
war against the straw hats and vegapunk
and vegapunk Loki reveals a massive
mystery about the secret origins of
devil fruits oh and al-bath is coming up
next baby one piece is absolutely crazy
right now so let's get into it you guys
know how this works if you enjoy my
videos you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now for that YouTube algorithm and
if you're one of the over 50 of people
who watch my videos but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a huge
favor and subscribe right now we are
trying to awaken the true power of this
channel by hitting 2 million subscribers
so every single subscription counts
finally this video will contain One
Piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned the
previous chapter brought us back to
Egghead Island where Admiral kizaru and
Saint Jay Garcia Saturn along with a
hundred Marine ships nine Vice Admirals
and 30 thousand Sailors completely
surrounded the island this kind of force
makes even a buster call look like
Child's Play by comparison but the big
difference between this and a buster
call is that the world government can't
just destroy the entire Island and go
home they have to take the island while
preserving that which the world
government continues to be vital for
their interests that said though there
are definitely similarities to O'Hara
here because we saw Saturn ordering the
ship carrying researchers and
technicians who were evacuated from
Egghead earlier to be attacked and
destroyed just in case any of those
people happen to know too much so much
like O'Hara No Mercy is shown and the
mere possibility that someone knows too
much is enough for them to be ruthlessly
disposed of we also finally saw kizero
in action again as he used one of his
light beams to just straight up pew pew
a Sea Beast weapon out of existence that
said kisaru is still holding back
because as I said there are too many
important things on Egghead Island that
he cannot afford to accidentally destroy
he's at once sent omaru to Just
Surrender control of the island without
a fight but santomo refuses which means
that an epic battle for Egghead island
is inevitable one of the things that
make Head Island that the world
government wants to preserve is of
course York because they need her in
order to create more mother flame
weapons the mother flame is the
incredibly deadly weapon that destroyed
the entire Kingdom of La Lucia in mere
seconds the power plant which produces
these weapons is on Egghead Island and
York was the one who secretly sent one
of the weapons to the gorosei so that
they could destroy La Lucia with it
York's conditions for helping the
gorosei are to spare her and the
research laboratory on Egghead and to
make York a world Noble and just when it
seemed like York was the one making the
demands and calling the shots and the
world government starts thinking that
she must have used the seraphim to
subdue the straw hats it is suddenly
revealed that no York is not the one in
charge instead York is a prisoner and
she is talking to the world government
with zoro's sword pointing squarely at
her throat the straw hats vegapunk and
Bonnie are the ones in control and even
cp0 seems to have possibly switched
sides that are now backing the straw
hats Luffy and the straw hats are the
ones in control of Egghead and if the
world government wants to take it they
will have to go through yonko Luffy and
his crew the latest chapter is called
Admiral kizaru and for good reason
because after so much waiting and so
much anticipation we finally get to see
kizaru engaging in a real full-on battle
but the chapter begins with Luffy taking
control of the denden Mushi that York
had been speaking through and then
addressing the gorosei directly Luffy
says hello I am Monkey D Luffy I'm the
man who will become the pirate king side
note but just the fact that Luffy
addressed the gorosei directly and
openly declared himself the next pirate
king is such an epic make an important
moment we really are into one piece end
game and that is so hard to accept after
all these years but it's also an amazing
moment to be a one-piece fan Luffy
states that the straw hats are in an
alliance with Dr vegapunk and if the
gorosei care about York's safety they
must withdraw their Fleet the only
person more excited for Luffy's speech
than the fans themselves is Morgans who
is tapping the call which means that he
is probably not too far away Morgans is
of course pumped to see how interesting
things are going to get over on Egghead
Island and I'm sure he's going to try
and get as close as possible to the
action then in another moment of surreal
epicness the gorosei in mariswa actually
speak to Luffy directly they say your
straw Hat Luffy correct who is alive
with you in label phase right now Luffy
begins to answer but Robin shouts at him
not to say anything and the call ends
the gurose recognize the voice of Robin
the devil child herself and this only
emphasizes the similarities between this
situation and O'Hara and it also further
stresses just how important Egghead
Island and everyone on it right now are
for the world government the people and
the information currently located on
this one Island have the potential to
bring everything crashing down upon the
gorosei and the world government and so
the godose have to do everything in
their power to neutralize these threats
as soon as possible despite Luffy's
confidence and optimism in that call
there is no way that the world
government will willingly withdraw
Saturn declares that three things must
be protected on the island the physical
safety of York the safety of punk
records which constitute vegapunk's
brain and finally the power plant that
is needed to produce the mother flame
weapon at the end of the day for a world
Noble like Saturn humans are no
different from insects even if their
numbers are reduced just a bit they'll
just multiply again so there's no need
to worry about protecting them even if
they happen to be on the world
government's payroll so yeah that means
that all the government agents on
Egghead are fair game back on the island
York says that if the straw hats do
anything to hurt her the entire Island
will be wiped out of existence just like
Ohara my girl Nami isn't having any of
that and she begins to give York a
well-deserved beat down to the point
that the others start feeling sorry for
the traitor I said it before and I'll
say it again Nami is a highly underrated
character she's definitely a major
Contender for best girl in the entire
series okay quick comment section
challenge who is best girl in one piece
in your opinion the most liked comment
wins all the glory and receives the
title of the ultimate one-piece waifu
Warrior moving on Lilith explains that
two vegapunk satellites are dead and
four are heavily injured so even though
the good guys are currently in control
of Egghead they did pay a heavy price
for York's betrayal fail the two
satellites that died are Shaka and
Pythagoras but since they are artificial
Creations it's possible that vegapunk
can just bring them back in the future
you gotta remember that punk records are
basically like the cloud and they store
all that information outside of the
bodies of vegapunk and the satellites so
presumably the minds of Shaka and
Pythagoras are still in there somewhere
they just have to be transferred into
new vessels meanwhile the government
agents in the underground basement area
are still technically the enemies of the
straw hats but in reality they're
actually happy to be alive and they're
grateful to the straw hats for saving
them and giving them food they are all
pretty much in the same boat now the
gorosei and the world government want to
achieve their three objectives on
Egghead and they are prepared to
sacrifice all the government agents on
the island if that's what it takes
essentially the lives of the agents are
in just as much danger as the lives of
the straw hats now while the
run-of-the-mill government agents are
happy to be alive and fed they are not
as happy to stuck down there in the
basement with the seraphim Vega Puck
assures everyone that the bubbles that
the seraphim are currently trapped
inside are the same bubble Shields used
by the pacifista Mark III there is
actually bomb proof and they are made
with the same properties as C prism
stone meaning that they are especially
effective against all devil fruit users
as snake even tells the government agent
NPCs to chill out because the seraphim
did not receive any orders to eliminate
them so they have no reason to worry
right after that Frankie takes the
opportunity to thank s snake for helping
that by undoing her petrification of the
straw hats and the fact that she did
that in the first place confuses
vegapunk because he doesn't remember
programming her to act that way we then
see a quick flashback in which Luffy is
standing eye to eye with a snake he
calls her Hancock and he asks her to
undo her powers on his comrades he says
please you're the only one who can save
them and S snake gives in saying okay I
will undo it so please stop staring at
my eyes directly it is clear that she
also has a major crush on Luffy just
like the original Boa Hancock jinbei
laughs because s snake is such a perfect
copy of Hancock that she looks down on
everyone except for Luffy just like the
original Hancock and vegapunk finds this
extremely interesting and he begins to
take notes he himself didn't even know
this but it seems that emotions are one
of the pieces of information that are
transferred through the lineage Factor
during the cloning process and although
this might seem just like minor info
that we get in passing this is actually
a lot more important than many people
realize in fact I'm working on a video
right now that explains just how
important the lineage factor is for
devil fruits and for Luffy's Nika devil
fruit in particular even though Oda has
hinted at this multiple times most
people don't really understand the true
connection between Luffy Joy boy and sun
god Nika and that is exactly what I will
be covering in that video subscribe
right now and hit the notification Bell
so you don't miss the video when it
comes out Luffy smiles and thanks as
snake again calling her Hancock again
and she gets all shy and lovey-dovey and
she asks him if he said that he loves
her honestly this is pretty funny it's
almost like Luffy is a master
manipulator who manipulated a snake into
getting exactly what he wants from her
but we know that he didn't really
manipulate her at least not
intentionally he just asked nicely and
sincerely and she couldn't help but
oblige now even though Luffy was talking
big during that call with the gorosei he
and the straw hats are not all that Keen
on betting their lives on a brutal
battle to the death against a fleet of
100 ships in reality they want to find a
way to escape the island but they can't
get out until they disable the frontier
Dome barrier York locked everything
using a secret password and she didn't
share the info with the punk records so
the other satellites don't know what the
password is if they do manage to escape
vegapunk decides that he and the straw
hats will be heading to the island of
the Giants elbaf and as soon as Luffy
and usop hear the word elbaf they freak
out because they've been waiting to go
there ever since little garden they
stopped paying attention to the
conversation and just start singing
about elbaf but while they enjoy
themselves Vega Puck and the others have
to actually figure out a way to get off
the island first they can't just leave
from the coast because the island is
completely surrounded so their only hope
is to leave by air they have to get Vega
Force 1 to carry the Thousand Sunny off
the island and then once they leave the
airspace of Egghead Island the Thousand
Sunny will take over and use Kuda burst
to fly them another kilometer away from
the island that will hopefully be far
enough to outrun the Marine ships and to
escape their attackers Atlas says that
it's a good plan and everything but
first they still have to disable the
frontier Dome barrier or else they can't
escape at all not to mention the fact
that they also have kisado out there and
if anyone has the speed to catch up to
the Thousand Sunny even while it's
flying through the air it's kizaru since
York refuses to give up the password
vegapunk Atlas and Edison get to work on
hacking it while Lilith Bonnie and the
straw hats make preparations to escape
as soon as the barrier goes down Lilith
says she never left Egghead before so
she's actually kind of excited to travel
while Luffy and Bonnie Bond over how
much they're going to miss the food on
Egghead once they leave Bonnie then
realizes that Sanji might just be the
perfect man for her and thus a new ship
set sail even before the Thousand Sunny
okay guys I gotta ask do you ship Bonnie
and Sanji I haven't thought about this
much before but honestly I think it kind
of works meanwhile Rob Lucci managed to
contact the Marines and thanks to the
Intel that he secretly gave them they
now believe that they know what's
happening inside whether or not Lucci
gave them all the correct Intel is
another matter but either way Saturn
believes that they now have to act he
tells kizaru that as a light human he
should be able to infiltrate the
frontier Dome since it uses laser-based
defense systems Kiza replies that yeah
it's possible but the man who is
currently guarding the Dome appears to
be an old friend of kizarus Saturn tells
him to just ignore his friend but kizuru
says that this would be disrespectful
moreover if they start attacking now
that for
will order the mecca sea beasts and the
pacifistas to attack the fleet which
will lead to mass casualties for the
Marines
Saturn is frustrated that the situation
has become so complicated but kizaru
says that thanks to Luchi they now have
all the Intel they need including the
location of the power plant as the
Marine Fleet assumes Battle Stations
it's clear that a massive assault on
Egghead is about to begin Luffy and the
straw hats finally reached the sunny but
at around the same time kizaru uses
yatano kagami to become light itself and
to infiltrate Egghead Island since
tomorrow then orders the pacifistas to
attack the Invaders and then he
confronts kizaru face to face santomaru
proclaims that his defense is the
strongest in the world as he collides
directly with the Admiral the chapter
ends as Luffy senses that someone very
strong is coming and so the all-out war
for Egghead Island begins man this was
such a great chapter we got so much
information about what happened during
the time Skip and what the straw hats
are planning to do next and we got some
huge important moments like Luffy
declaring himself to be the next pirate
king to the Goro State directly and
kizaru infiltrating Egghead Island and
joining the action after all this time
it's clear that the straw hats are not
interested in a battle to the death
against the Marines they want to escape
with everything they need and live to
fight another day but that doesn't mean
that their escape will be easy even if
they can outrun everyone else with their
aerial Escape Plan they can't outrun
kizaru and I think that before this Arc
ends we will see Luffy versus kizaru
let's be honest centubaru can't hold off
the Admiral forever so I do expect him
to clash with Luffy and the straw hats
directly before they make their escape
what do you guys think is gear 5 Luffy
versus full power kizaru about to happen
are you excited for elbaf how epic was
it to hear Luffy tell the Goro say
directly that he will be the next pirate
king let me know down below oh if you're
looking for an epic one-piece video to
watch next check out our video on all 12
mythical Zone devil fruits explained and
ranked from weakest the strongest Link
in the description and on screen right
now if you enjoyed this video you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like right now and if you watch my
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell right now we are trying to hit 2
million subscribers on the channel and
every subscription counts